previously on the forest god
in heaven we missed a katana says chad
we missed a katana oh katana
there's a flashlight flashlight oh my
god oh that's
way better all right so where's the next
cave at nerds
it's in the big village
okay this is a village if only it was at
nighttime somewhere in here
there's an entrance aha here got it
there's a guy over here who's
absolutely been sacrificed we should go
in the hole they're coming
we should go in the hole they're coming
[Laughter]
do
god damn oh that was so funny to me but
god damn it was the plain way i
exclaimed that they're
coming not even that we should go in the
hole
they're coming
up here there's a battery we got battery
you guys need alcohol
there's a battery in one of these oh
[ __ ] there is battery okay
no that was hairspray wait i think what
you thought was a battery was actually
hair spray
yeah do you have any because there's a
bottle over here i can grab so if you oh
wow you have it on a tray wow wow yeah
this is the new this is a good [ __ ]
oh thank you for dropping the booze i'm
going to make these into milo topped yak
deals
oh we got the map baby map right here
map oh god it's not filled out
right now it's not [ __ ] map if it's
not it's just paper
well yeah what do you think map's made
out of
a jealous god punishes a parent's fault
on their children what does this mean
this is [ __ ]
it means kids are a-holes
hey big comp energy
dude
i like company i love comping dude the
compass does not
emit light can i just say that i don't
know why it should
i would appreciate something that does
that made you chuckle it made you
chuckle and you hate yourself for it but
it did
it did that's my that's my real laugh
the true laugh it's so good it's more
than i usually get i'll take it
i'll take it
is there a hotkey to comp i don't know
do you need one
i like this oh the map has a little
light on it if you pull the map out it
just has a clip-on
batter a clip-on led light yeah
yeah look yeah it's cute that's cute
[ __ ] we have two pads again
i'll go left i combine tape compass and
lighter can i please have lighter
compass
can i light my map on fire and
then i'd see more what is the point of
this oh that's the
hey wade how's it going oh good bob oh
mark there's an
m16 down here there's a what
there's a gun yeah we got a
realzy's gun over here and a toy i don't
trust you
you're goofing with me i would never
goof i'm not coming
back it's a trick oh don't go this way
don't go that way
why there's people up there yeah well
there's people my way too
so i was sort of hoping your way would
be cool
ow you gonna come get your gun mark i'm
not i'm going
further into the cave oh lots of rocks
i'm glad they gave us bullets for this
instead of rocks
okay do you think that all of these
caves connect
because this map is very large like
we're filling out like nothing
whoa hey double two for the price of
[ __ ]
oh god oh god oh god there's people over
here oh god
dude they just keep coming all right i'm
coming to see this gun
and awfully use it you're gonna love it
mark i can't wait for it i
i already love it don't don't groan at
me i'm stuck
i i'm stuck i'm i'm fine all these all
these strings with like fingers on them
are much
firmer than they look where's this gun
oh my god
look at this hole i definitely want to
go in oh you'll find it mark just keep
looking
i mean there's got to be some kind of
like scuba gear or something because we
can't there's no way we can yeah
i think you have to explore this hole i
think that it suits you
yeah there's a there's definitely scuba
gear oh hey that big battery symbol is
definitely the hairspray i found more
oh wow cassette player yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we do where
where is that
right in the backpack next to the
walkie-talkie we have a walkie-talkie
yeah we could talk to each other i don't
see the cassette player did i not get it
was it i uh i've got cassettes no except
i think it was on the boat oh
yeah we're yeah we can go back to the
boat i don't know exactly where it was
but we can go get those turtle shells
it's not a big deal mark did you get
your gun i know i
couldn't find it where was it hey you
wait you know what mark you wanna know
where your gun is
where you just gotta swim down into this
hole oh yeah
okay uh no i'm not gonna do that come on
man we'll go together come here
we'll jump in together come on all right
okay come on buddy you ready yeah
three two one yippee
wow well like you didn't mark didn't
come with me
no bob you're really going down there oh
my god guys it's dark
um oh it's really dark how's your breath
i'm at half breath i didn't want to use
that half to come back
god i wouldn't oh god all right
oh baby that's dark let me uh guys how's
it going do you think the flashlight
works underwater i'm gonna just really
quickly oh boy oh my god no it doesn't
i'm coming back no you gotta go you
gotta go no coming up you gotta go in
mark
back in there i'll illuminate the path
of someone who goes down that's what
okay
you shine flashlight in can you guys
know the fire up here for when i come
back
yeah we'll get it
that does not do anything it's dark
can you change your angle at all no no
it's really uh it looks like
i gotta let you know it looks just as
dark and scary from even up higher oh
okay i'm gonna come back up now
all right cool oh yeah good you do that
oh i don't have as much breath as i
thought i did
uh yeah whoops
i'm fine you're fine okay good anybody
make that fire for old bobby boy
no no no no no no well oh
i'll make you a fire you need a fire you
got it you just please you seem to have
it oh okay
you need me to buy it i could do it you
know i mean i'm freezing to death here
but i can
i mean i don't understand why you oh
okay well i was about to sure
i really was check my vod check my vod
check my vod
oh i don't want to check your bod check
my baud worried where are you
right above you what oh there you are
okay there's a rope that takes you up
right here okay where do we go lads
uh i'm not sure there's a drawing up
here i don't know if there's anything
more down that way or not but there was
a drawing up here
well you know how i care about lore i'm
definitely gonna come get that
your kid drew it so [ __ ] hate that
guy
i see i see oh this is a bad one oh wow
this is crap oh
more clothings oh hey these things
to the chairs airplane shirts that's
what their chairs is
i thought this was the top it was some
kind of like weird keyboard i'm an idiot
don't mind me
my guess is all these caves will
eventually connect if you get the scuba
gear because you could then go through
the water
is there anything in this cave other
than the map we need to be looking for
yeah there's an
axe a better axe but i don't know if if
that's important to you
that seems important well let me look at
like uh let me look at another um
another map and see like what actual
items we would need
okay weirdly enough the submerged cave
is where you get the rebreather and
there's another flashlight there
there's a shipwreck cave with a crossbow
in it but you need the rebreather to get
it
and then the lawyer's cave has a key
card
and a camcorder bob you have a cave
not a lawyer technically what why did i
pay you all that money
well we gotta get the rebreather if we
want that
okay where is that that would wait do we
need the rebreather to get the axe in
here
it doesn't seem like it but it's only a
better axe and whip so if we
really for chopping down all we need is
the chainsaw
but we could go to the submerged cave to
get the rebreather which would allow us
to get more stuff and then swing up and
get
the camcorder and the key card for
whatever reason
would that be for the wasn't there
something we needed for the boat yes
that might be the key cards that might
be it was the boat they're floating
was the boat working is that how we get
out is that how this
[ __ ] ends did we just take the boat
that'd be nice
i like boat well either way i think
we're pretty okay if we don't want the
axis fine
but we could get the rebreather because
then they would allow terrifying
exploration
into holes yeah we should do that you
guys okay
hey mark how's it going what are you
doing you want to join in yeah man
i like the little gasp you let out when
you block
all right shall we yeah all right
i accidentally sliced you with my sword
that's not how you block where's his gun
by the way i didn't see the gun
it's right where the axe the new axe is
but we missed the axe too
you guys and your lies i'm stuck
i'm stuck mark you just gotta
the gun to squeeze through right of
course okay so we got to take a left and
then
get out of here wait does that mean the
axe was to the right
i don't know man i don't know where the
axe was i think i want the axe
axe was a myth it doesn't exist we it
we'll never get it we don't need it
who needs the axe not us oh i'm inside
somebody
bob did you start blocking immediately
too yeah
we did that in unison as we got mark is
also doing it
oh yes it's the only way to live
hey are there bad things awaiting us up
top ah
no way nothing up here
sunshine it's beautiful actually is that
just bone piled you can't
interact with drums you guys hearing
drums in the deep
drums in the deep oh it's not drums
what is it is it stepper whoa what is it
what is it
it's big oh what is that
whoa i we need to get out of here
oh my god go
my god you think we can take it down i'm
afraid of what it does
i well what can it do i'll go in i'm not
afraid of that oh i'm afraid oh god this
is the thing
wade we saw this before
oh my god are you dead i'm fine
it didn't hurt at all actually made him
bait him to charge into the trees okay
maybe like that
oh god help guys anytime you want to
join in
i'm baiting him over
oh he turns on a dime here
please kill him
he turns like an absolute oh
no stompies
are you okay
i hate medicine i need i need
you just gotta you just gotta escape the
swamp
oh oh
escape better than i did meds i'm
pissing off with the rocks
oh
hey that was easy all right cool grab
your goop yeah i'm getting my groove oh
yeah i'm putting on the goop there we go
yeah we're good oh no there's nothing
out of him what happened on the ground
okay uh follow me if you want to go to
the submerged cave
that man had a moves that i could say
that
that guy could go he freaking
he he go he he runs he goes
mover yeah he go here's the plane okay
we're back at the plane
that ass though oh my god yeah
oh no was the plane where the cassette
thing was
uh no that's by the yacht yeah i don't
really have the plane on here
well that seems like an obvious landmark
that should be on a map but i really
should yeah but it's not
shouldn't have [ __ ] with me i got a
sword now
[Music]
oh you can charge up the katana strike
you hold it yet again
way more damage yeah okay so somewhere
we're going to find another village oh
then
jesus then our sorry we're fine then
around that village
there's going to be two cave entrances
but one is to the cave we were just in
and the other will be to a new cave
but we got to find the village first
okay i found a cave entrance
but i'm not sure which cave it is oh
actually the map works out here too oh
interesting i think this might be the
right one
my map has nothing on it though well you
gotta write it in
how do you write it i'm going down well
you walk around that doesn't seem right
oh my god
are we going back up oh my
god hey legs how's it going
oh you guys are going confidently down
i stopped i didn't pause the moment
oh my god
to get chainsaws out and just go
freaking ham maybe
maybe that's the only way maybe that's
the best way
i can't oh molotov could be good
well we we would need a safe spot to do
that i'm not worried about the little
ones so much
uh the legs are aiming at me yeah the
legs are not happy
all right do you want me to be the first
one down and tank this bad boy
uh well we three two one and then we'll
just go for it
all right count this in fearless leader
all right wade you heard the man
three two one
oh god it hurts really bad
oh okay i need to back off and take a
minute i'm under
oh god one shot i'm almost dead okay one
shot
i took a med going back for more change
it hurts oh my god it hurts a lot
yeah i need to med for a second yeah do
we have any mollies do we have any
molotovs
i don't know i'm equipping mine i i i
don't even
know i got one i'm hitting i'm hitting
it maybe they stack i'm just gonna go
for it
okay get more i guess
okay we got doesn't seem to like that
it's it seems to be aggroed on never
mind it's aggroed on you
it's egg right on you okay all right i'm
letting another molotov
i i'll have mine ready after
you got wait bring it over here god damn
it i'm laying it
oh my god it can't shut up okay it lit
it lit you got that we got that going
for us
i can't see through the hell he said it
said okay i'm putting this back in my
pocket apparently
done oh time to grab some goop easy
pretty simple stuff gang where'd all
those babies go who even cares
a bunch of nerd babies they died of
exposure because they were babies
yeah yeah they did all right well that
was good that went well apparently
there's a rebreather somewhere down here
cool cool cool cool wow that's a lot of
babies
oh lord where do they come from
oh we're we're in a thing called baby
cave
oh good yay i have bad news according to
the map
this isn't a new cave this is actually
just the exit
from the cave we were just in we didn't
need to come here
at all uh there's also tape in a lot of
these suitcases
oh tape i haven't seen tape in a while
and medicines
oh and chainsaw ammo which is good since
i just used that
all right you know this was worth it
this is worth it so i'm really glad we
got that experience mark i appreciate
you
appreciate you exposing us to that just
for practice
yeah yeah you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome we were relatively
efficient
dealing with the horrible goop monster
and it's yeah rude we're getting better
all right now if i'm reading the map
correctly yep you haven't done that yet
like if you're holding the map out while
you move it is just your screen is this
map
yeah there's some rocks around us i see
rock yeah definitely i see suitcases
suitcases
can i spear them yes i can and if i look
at my map
i see nothing man there's not a lot of
landmarks that i'm writing on this map
maybe it's night and i can't
write as good we're approaching
something
something something over here got it
oh is this the beach with the boat no
this is a
different beach oh
i missed it all right yes this
is the one my dudes this is the one
isn't this where we were
no no no it's different are you sure
yeah it's different yeah it's different
very different oh there's some people
moving in the darkness
oh there's some guys over there yeah
it's new oh you don't trust
me crouch never mind
what you bunch of babies you're afraid
to attack afraid of killing
afraid of murder are you afraid of
murder afraid of murder
yeah yeah
all right hey this guy looks relatively
intact oh it's the pilot
there's a path up over here yeah
somewhere in here is the
the uh the rebreather i'm guessing it's
down and not up
maybe oh i remember there being a
drawing about this
wall with the crosses on it yeah too bad
bam oh i like the picture of the trees
with the pit hole
gross roots oh
hi hi friend come closer
oh he's got a friend of a friend oh god
i'm good with that one
oh yeah you're coming bob
we'll save you it's kind of awkward yeah
a little bit i don't think he can reach
me though so i think it's okay
it's only awkward for him oh there's a
hole
great not 100 sure about the hole but
there is a hole
another flashlight
oh i got the batteries from it oh that's
nice
oh nice oh that is handy
bam oh there was a secret helmet
i'm glad i opened that up i like holes
i'm gonna go down in the hole
oh i just almost left in the hole this
is probably fine
that's probably oh it's not that deep
okay we're fine no there's more hole
can't see okay
probably fine most of the time when we
go down in these holes it ends up being
completely fine
it's gorgeous actually the entire cave
just collapsed on my head behind me dude
rebreather oh hell yeah right here
oh cool where right here do we only have
like a
limited amount of this yeah it's an air
canister
so are we supposed to go in here then i
think that the idea is that you use it i
don't know
why but i'm gonna try it all right
let's go go baby oh it's got a built-in
light
oh it's so much a built-in autofocus
feature
[ __ ] fuzz vision oh i'm sorry can you
guys see
perfectly underwater at all times are
you really going slow here
wait how are you so pretty oh it's
lovely what's the horrible screeching
noise
i don't hear a horse oh oh that horrible
oh good oh wow
ah frick okay don't forget to like take
off your thing or something
the way they just fly anybody else
freezing to death
oh what the hell
ow i'm gonna make a fire yeah yes please
thank you
oh is this another tank ooh free tank
there's another tank over here
so i'm guessing there's a little bit
farther to go ah
oh get the water in the water get the
water
it doesn't put you out of the water
oh you automatically put on the
rebreather when you go in the water oh
that's andy
all right i'm gonna carry on
wow all right well i guess i'm going off
on my own then
uh no i'm behind you have fun dying more
i won't
i don't want to i'm far enough behind
you if you die that i can turn around go
back to bob
all right cool man nothing another new
thing what the
hell is this oh no
in the hell oh gosh
oh my goosh rock rock
oh my god who knew the secret code was
rock
we uh i need to i need to torch it up or
something
yeah does anyone have a torch they can
light what are you guys
doing over here
what what there's a camp here
it's unnecessary guys what you checking
out
over here so how did they just die
in these poses can we grab your bible
wait you are making not the discoveries
you think you're making and just come
over here and look
come look at the real important stuff
after i get this real important stuff
like this campfire lit
ooh this art wow that looks good
is this a better oh there's an axe
better oh what
what rusty axe anyway i don't know if
that's better
oh yeah i don't know if that's better
but it's an axe it's the rusty yeah it's
rusty
it has 100 block stat wow
it's the rust all right i'm going to
carry on
momento por favor all right i'll wait
okay i'm here under the sea i'm gonna
take advantage of this fire
i cannot see we
just because it's what i really want to
go back to the hole now you can discover
all the mysteries of the hole
oh i'm sure we'll get there i'm sure i'm
sure let me look at my map while i'm
swimming i'm just gonna
follow these well-preserved bibles yeah
it is a little strange how they're
floating
only here oh hey way out is that it
i guess the only thing in here was a
rebreather yeah and the actual
axe and the axe okay well that was fun
you guys don't want to warm up before
you yeah
up there is where it's warm uh question
we are
far from home but uh you know i gotta go
soon
hey we can warm up here that was not a
question
but the answer is yeah we should
probably go home huh well we don't
we could build a camp out here or we
could go i think that's faster than just
walking home
how long does it take you to build a
camp long time
yeah you're right let's go home scuba
dive some more oh god all right
i forgot it spoils if you carry around
raw meat oh
what is oh god oh this is
horrible horrible
why would you do this
under the sea oh my god you guys might
hate what you're about to do
oh hi ducks oh hi actually i love that
that was very nice
hello gooses hi goosies it's kind of a
long trek home but we'll make it
hello dear excuse me we've used up a lot
of the meat so i'm gathering all the
deer i can to hang some more meat up
when we get back
ah meat schmee that's what i always say
you've never said that
that's what i always say oh my god guys
dynamite knocks down trees
what is that what my screen just shook
for yeah
why were you casually experimenting with
dynamite i was just i hadn't gotten to
throw one and i was just curious about
how that works
oh there's babies okay okay
okay i don't get how you guys it's like
go home and then you guys somehow go on
this mysterious adventure
i'm like right behind you mark i don't
know what you're talking so much smack
about that
well i'm hearing about babies and
dynamite so you
literally ran straight to your name with
dynamite
while i was running home that's fair
the rules against running with dynamite
very different from running with
scissors i imagine
what items are we still missing by the
way from the future caves
we need like a key card uh recorder
and yeah the kid's somewhere around here
somewhere
the kid the key card and the bouchard
the bouchard yeah i threw dynamite but i
didn't light it
well i did that with the molotov at the
big monster earlier
nice hey mark hey what's up
catch oh my god
not a funny prank not gonna lie i'm re i
was real tempted to actually light one
and throw it and say the same thing
i didn't that would be not so good for
our base
of operations yeah i saved the game boys
all right good well done
it looks like we're almost done with
this we'll get off this
island and leave all our troubles behind
we'll get off
we'll be comfy and real soon yeah we're
gonna come back and comfy it up
yeah man we'll be comfy until we get a
long cabin
or a gazebo or something without
ultimately destroying it
yeah that's a possibility
you